hey can you confirm my numbers for me
please this add up to 30 30 amigo one
adds up to 100
how convenient okay now how do we take
how do we take these two numbers and
arrive at what the denominator wants us
to get think about it carefully this
number here this 30 is here that's 30
it's the sum of all those take a breath
X take away X bars squared 30 right the
other one what's that number that's a
hundred right so to get out denominator
you're gonna go 30 times 100 yeah
thought following me so far which is
3,000 and then you take the square root
okay so what we're gonna get out of that
you can write this down underneath here
okay yes so it's the square root of
3,000 which you said it again 50 okay
thank you I assume okay so how do we
then take those we're pretty much there
okay we're taking that 51 which we did
work out earlier all the way over here
and then we're also taking this was it
fifty four point seven seven and we're
dividing one by the other
okay so we're gonna get a value of R
which equals 51 divided by this fifty
four point seven seven business what do
you get zero point nine three can you
give me a few more one one oh I missed
that one one what six
okay I'm happy there all right okay so
say again
- oh did I miss I miss the digit today
well guess what
I can I can settle this argument do you
ever I told you to remote old Union this
thing here right this is how to work out
this Pearson correlation coefficient
this is a very laborious process as you
can see we only had five data points
okay it's a very laborious process which
is why the syllabus doesn't demand that
you know how to do this it demands that
you know how to use this okay so get
your calculator out now okay all right
so can you see that clearly is that all
right so get your calculator there first
thing is make sure everything's cleared
out because you know if you're in the
wrong mode I can think it's quite
confused if you've got extra data saved
in there from the last time you used it
so if you can't remember shift 9 and
lastly if you want to clear we want to
clear everything so that's a three and
then follow the buttons and you'll get
this we've cleared it all out okay now
handily all of these instructions are in
your book as well but what you want to
do first is got to mode and then ask you
do you want to compute stuff do you want
to work out some statistics or do you
want verify some stuff which do you
think we want option two for statistics
okay now look carefully at mister second
have a look now so far in statistics
you've stayed in that first option 1-var
just take a wild stab in the dark where
you think it stands for that's 1/5
stands for one variable
okay now I'm hopefully there's no part
that says to var but if you have a look
at the second option what does it say
the second option a plus BX that those
two things are your two variables you
have eight okay so let's all hit two and
if you've done this right it's ready to
accept
[Music]
if you've done this right it's ready now
to set some data QC the two columns
there you got it
okay so go ahead and input all of those
bits of data into your X and your Y
columns so when you hit a number like
say six if you press equals it goes down
to the next row okay so it asks you to
put all the ones in one variable it just
makes it easier seven nine ten whoops
not forty sorry thirteen and then you
want to put your wise in C you use your
use your little cursor pad up here go
all the way to the top and then you can
cursor to the right to putting your Y
values once you put all your data in yes
you can once your data is all there I
just need to play catch-up
hey see
[Music]
okay now just a quick one before you
clear if you haven't cleared already it
is worth just scrolling back up really
quickly through your data and just check
the input it right like the number of
times I've pressed a button twice or I
thought I pressed one but I did it and
of course that's gonna completely mess
up your data you're gonna get it to do a
calculation and you won't know whether
it was right or wrong okay so check that
it's all there have you got it all once
you've done that you can clear it so
press AC okay the data is still there in
the background so follow this part
closely press shift on your calculator
press shift and then if you're go to
your keypad you see up above one
what's it say there above one stat so
you got a whole bunch of options here
one for stat okay now your options here
are interesting you got all different
things that you're looking for for
reasons it'll become clear later we're
gonna hit five for our eg I'll explain
what that is once we're done with the
calculator rich now I've already told
you what we call correlation what do we
call it we're looking for the R which is
3 right so press 3 I will come in and
then hit the equals button oh snap ok so
yes I do wonder where that 6 came from
anyway it doesn't matter all right so
you got there now go back to your book
go back to your book where you've got
this written down ok where you've got
this written down even though it's in
your book right here ok I'm going to ask
you to write these steps with me to get
them into your brain
ok so here's what we did yep yep yep
[Applause]
you can but the problem is this takes
like 15 minutes for a small data set you
Franco you don't have 15 minutes to play
with right I've given this to you so you
know what on earth is doing but you
don't have time you don't have time okay
all right so I'm just gonna clear a bit
of space but underneath this or perhaps
beside let's just quickly rehearse what
those steps were on your calculator okay
and maybe you can help me
step one what was the very first thing
we did clear the data thank you
I'm not gonna bother putting the the
actual buttons in because I think you
can you can work that out but you need
to clear stuff right then we had to get
into a particular mode what mode was
that stats mode okay so that was step
two when you're in stat mode there's a
bunch of different stats modes
you know we're usually in one variable
mode but we don't want one variable mode
we want bivariate data what was the
thing that said bivariate data a plus BX
so let's just write that down as a
little some point there okay
once you hit that BAM you get your
columns up what was our step once we did
that when we saw the columns what are we
putting there Eric so now why so enter
your data okay do a bit of data entry
okay step four then we get to play with
that data once we get it okay now this
thing I did say you like you're going to
press some buttons you're going to go
back into stat mode right which you can
see in the bottom left hand corner where
it says stat on your keyboard
keypad I should say and then I promised
that I would explain that thing which
says are eg what does that stand for
it stands for regression this is the
word that we use when we're trying to
get a sense of the trend or something is
there a trend or not
you guys saw those trend lines that we
had a look at over here
remember these things so these trend
lines right there also called lines of
regression because it's about is there a
trend or not okay
mrs. Lee's please yes which is a really
good opportunity to point out if you go
back into mode don't press shift just
press mode then go to and then remember
how we saw all these 1-var and then
there's this bivariate thing which is
number two just pull us from them and
look at the rest of them pause you're a
look at the rest of them you're like
whoa what are all these things have a
guess what do you think you know number
three that's not modeling things with a
straight line what do you think number
three is more like with have a look
closely at it just have a guess
number three says this what do you think
that means to not model ink with a
straight line it's modeling with our
kind of shape is that it's a parabola
right number four what do you think it
number fours trying to model here if
it's a logarithm right number five
that's an exponential and on and on and
on okay
all right last one once you've put in
regression what was the what was the
thing we were searching for what's it
called it's called R and that's what
gets you to the piece in correlation
coefficient okay are there any questions
we've covered a lot of ground yeah joy
shea-porter smoke do you remember your
like I have no idea what I was talking
about yeah very good yeah excellent so
just think you can catch what Moe is
talking about here this is a nominator I
haven't dwelled on it because it's just
such gross arithmetic I didn't want you
to sort of get lost in the woods what
this is doing is there's a name to this
by the way I might even write it down
for you the name for this is called
normalizing because you'll notice that
this number is always between negative 1
and 1 it doesn't care what you're
measuring it doesn't care if you're
measuring the temperature of a summer's
day which is you know whatever between
25 and 40 or something like that or if
you're measuring the temperature of a
star which is in like thousands of
degrees Kelvin whatever doesn't care
what scale you're on doesn't care what
units you're talking about this thing
down here it normalizes so whatever
units you had going on up here whatever
scale I kind of accounted for in this
denominator that's kind of what that
numerical magic is doing that's really
clever the way they designed it